only congrats are you doing with artists
here so I'm like how you doing I'm fine
how are you bro judgement television TV
505 yes I said welcome here from Bosnia
Sarajevo you know welcome it is August
he is welcome here in Bosnia he's very
popular here in Boise and there is a lot
of young especially young people who
follows his show here in Bosnia so as he
explained me now he met some of them in
our streets in Sarajevo and he is very
popular here come delight and Sharla as
we will help him mashaallah to record
some some new shows here in Bosnia with
new stories very interesting stories
about about people from Bosnia and in
Sabah Eddie will show some interesting
interesting stories here ISA got a lot
coming guys stay tuned with channel 5
others here helping us out
Sonic
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm leaking guys how you doing
bringing you some wonderful stories here
in Bosnia survival and I met another
fascinating brother I'm here how you
doing
I'm doula how are you so you're
originally you were from the States huh
I'm from Canada I mean a Bosnian yeah
born in Bosnia migrated to Canada in
1996 yeah as a refugee in but so now but
now you're in Dubai yeah I live there
right now yes yeah how do you from the
outside looking you were in the inside
outside you know there's a lot of
Islamophobia right and there's so many
negative things that people are trying
to correlate with Islam like when you
meet someone in Dubai in American and
whatnot they get to actually intermingle
with a lot of Muslim how is the
atmosphere there how many how much
traffic do you get from Americans coming
over to to Dubai and that's one of the
most developed countries in the world
isn't that tell yeah yeah Dubai is a
multicultural place it's a city within
United Arab Emirates
it has over 200 nationalities so it's
very multicultural place has a lot of
lot of different people and panella
because you know it's it's a Muslim
country so people get to interact with
Muslims a lot and all those all those
things that people think about Muslims
they kind of get broken down because
they see Muslims there in action you
know they hear the other and they go to
the mosque and Ramadan is observed there
you know publicly you cannot eat in the
in public and stuff like that so people
respect that a lot and plus you know me
because it's a thorough place I mean
it's a through way in a way so a lot of
people stopped over even though they
don't maybe visit for like a you know a
week or something but they stopped for a
day or two millions of people visit
device it's the busiest airport in the
world by the way yeah but people who
haven't traveled they're stuck in there
like you know little town and somewhere
and you know the hills or whatever in
the south and they got these
misconceptions that you know Muslims are
terrorists and you know not every must
not every terrorist Muslim but every
Muslims are terrorism what do you say to
such a cliche oh you have to meet
Muslims you have to you have to
to them you have to interact with them
and you get to see the real picture I
mean I mean so many Americans from North
Carolina from from Tennessee from many
places and you know their picture
changed totally because they interact
with Muslims from all over the place
like I said the Dubai has Arab Muslims
as you know South Asian Muslims has you
know from all the Russian Republic's the
Muslims there to Bosnians although not
many of us and African Muslims it's it's
it's amazing when you go to a mosque I
mean America same thing when you go to
the Masjid and you see so many different
people and device like that just in a
large scale yeah and what's interesting
is some of these places that people try
to point to that are underdeveloped that
are kind of backwards where people say
these are most places let's safe gana
Stan Iraq you know that just been blown
back into the Stone Age
you know the means by foreign occupation
you know but if you look at like Dubai
it wasn't it wasn't under that so
Muslims were actually able to develop
you see the correlation oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah Dubai is one of the most
advanced places in the world and it has
one of the some of the largest number of
squares Christ creepers in the world
isn't the tallest building of course it
is yeah yeah it is
and you know they're building another
tall one and it has a think over three
hundred towers that are over 100 meters
tall so it's the largest number of
skyscrapers in the world as well and
it's a fast expanding city and you know
they always show this picture of the
buying 1990s comparing to 2012 and it's
like there was a desert in 1994 and
after that it's like a boom it's like
it's like basically Manhattan in a way
you know what what happened in your life
that had you to really talk to reflect
and think about purpose you know in
seeking purpose and now living purpose
what happened was you know the war
happened we we were refugees in Slovenia
for four years
and subhanAllah that's when that's when
you start kind of looking at things you
know what I have to live for today I
have to live for today and I have to
live I don't know what's gonna happen
tomorrow literally like nowadays we live
and we plan things ahead for a year two
years ten years down the road when
you're refugee you think about
to be alive tomorrow do I have food for
tomorrow do I have shelter for tomorrow
so those kind of things put in your mind
said what's my purpose here then so then
you you you you you you go back to Allah
and you get reminded look there's a
trial for you and subhanAllah I mean it
was a blessing in a way and we got
guided back to Allah to Islam what what
was it about Islam that stood out
because there's so many religions and
people are like all they try to put it
all in the same bunch o Islam is just
one of those you know another one of
those religions man-made what do you say
to that our I think it's the direct
relationship to Allah to God that there
is nobody to worship or nobody to ask or
nobody have to go through to have a
communication with God and this is the
most important thing in Islam is that
the relationship that you have a
personal relationship that you can go
alone at the depth of the night and
asking him and have a direct
relationship with him and no other
religion provides that and of course
also in Islam there is only Allah
there's none worthy of worship to be
worshipped except him and therefore it
all makes sense I mean you know you see
in a human scale that if you have two
people partners in something there's
always miss disagreement or something
like that imagine there's two gods or
three gods
god forbid it would be a disaster and
those kind of things was put in my mind
and you start thinking about it and then
reading Quran and then pondering upon
the Quran what allah subhanaw taala
revealed allah allah almighty revealed
in the quran it all that kind of it's
like a puzzle that just came together
mm-hmm
if tyrese he visits the by a lot if our
christian brother and Jude whoever just
I mean not yet Muslims I call if they're
visiting you know because that as a
pit-stop you know or people visiting to
Dubai is just huge and they want to
learn more about what we're talking
about can they hook up with you and
Dubai yeah for sure you can hook up with
me or you can hook up with Islamic
information center in Dubai there's
that'll good society there's so many
places there's so many so much
information you can get
in in anywhere in UAE and it's it's it's
a very good place in Japan Allah just
one more statistic for you every year
tens of thousands of people become
Muslim in in Dubai
what is the Muslim mean what does that
mean when you say Muslim means the one
who submits to to God that one yeah
mister God who is well yeah that's it
man it's simple Jesus was a Muslim Moses
was a Muslim
we're ones who submit to the will of God
the same way they did and last and final
messenger prophet muhammad peace be upon
them all and we started with peace with
peace may you have a blessed trip thank
you very very very much very wonderful
you know I'm trying went here and said I
ever run into some some wonderful people
and we have a mutual friend I want to
send your little bunny Gabriel Salam
alaikum rather all right thank ya slowly
come guys how you doing man I'm told you
I'm here in Bosnia meeting some
incredible people he's trying to bring
you some incredible stories this is
nothing how you doing Eddie I'm fine
thank you
continue on basically I was born in a
small town what has got to be accepted
and I was raised a rightly feared for my
life and during the war that's the
Bosnia is divided in two parts and this
part where I lived is under occupation
sort of Serb territory and basically or
all the mosques and all the religious
buildings and all the Devas no religious
life dear and all the Bosniaks left and
I stayed there with my my mother and my
aunt and my grandmother and we stayed
there for my life we still there through
that tough period and and I grow up in a
severe poverty
basically I had I didn't have one
Khayyam it basically
path Europe to have a drink and after
the war ended I was thinking you stay in
the same conditions basically it was so
small not a small house no no
electricity no water no toilets meets
very hard conditions
and when I was eight eighth grade of
elementary school I began to feel ill
and this illness it lasted for ten years
ten years almost killed me but that
illness was my biggest blessing because
because of that illness and there was no
cure and I began to think about the
world I did the thing about my life to
think about Allah and that that illness
brought me back to mosque that you must
brought me back to today and when I was
21 years old 2004 that was the first
time I went into a mosque that was in my
hometown was Katowice because the the
mosque was rebuilt in 2003 the first
time as an was here in my town after
eleven years and after that 2005 I
enrolled in mismanaging 2007 my illness
returned I felt worse and worse I start
bleeding
fevers basically nothing nothing could
stop the effects of the illness and so I
became moral moral that Ramadan I passed
the first day and then I fell ill then I
fall into into my bed I couldn't move my
my muscles they retracted I basically
had 40 kilos my stomach is floating in
five in five areas and I was put into a
intro clinical Center but they couldn't
help me I was basically in December of
that year 2007 I must have to die
and thanks to the good people from my
hometown basically mom the head imam of
measure disposal schedule pizza and i
was sent to sorry about the clinical
center i was i was operated in I had
operation third January of 2008 after
that two months I had the rehabilitation
learned how to walk there for diapers
learned how to eat I was like a baby
that here I in October I enrolled in
Turin here of Islamic faculty I finished
in 2010 I finished I think in half is a
memorise a phone memorize the whole
Quran are you kidding me yes so you the
D understand is one of the miracles of
the Quran like no other book in the
world memorized by millions and millions
of people and look at his situation look
I mean his health is deteriorated he's
coming back and you memorized the whole
book of Allah because we have a unique
tradition in Bosnia when you memorize
the quran you have to recite it
completely in 15 no more than 15 days
and it took me a while to complete that
I completed it last year I decided it
from 18th of May the 1st of June
complete Quran in front of the
Commission and that was the happiest
moment of my life basically
the most important person in my life
often is my mother and then I remember
what we got that we had one shoe to that
illness with that a terribly patient and
now the day that the three went to
Bosnia to Boston schedule bit sad that
was the final recitation final when I
receive diploma for Hafiz for
memorization I received it in my
hometown in the same mosque grads
kazamia vodka Moscow Indu beta where I
first entered the mosque in 21 years
when I prayed for a therapy for Saba
when I started to learn first there's
the place where I prayed my first to
Juma that place where I went the first
time on a Thursday and that was the
religion the Dean has changed my life
for the better and really I had found it
to be a very person who has who has
deemed the person who believes who has
on what I believe that now nothing can
stop him in this room basically your
body may become vehicle and may have
problems you may have illnesses you may
have tribulations but then you have
Allah is huge if you believe in Allah
that not just believe in all of us
believe Allah believe that everything
will be ok that after this tribulation
is for your good you will be stronger
you will be better and that's what I
said my English was basically my biggest
blessing in my life something that
almost killed me has made me where I am
today and I was thinking I was thinking
about that what would happen in my life
it tried even happiness with I would I
ever come to mosque would I ever learn
Quran would I ever read Quran would I
ever need this wonderful people would I
beat for speaking today it's you
a la works he works for us everything
that he gives us is basically for us for
our good maybe we don't see it right now
but it's for our good but believe me it
is and we can see it be seeds after
sometime when you see the big picture
so trust Allah feeling I'm not believe
in Allah remember Allah and your body
and your psychology your depression
anxiety tribulations they are no they
are basically no problem and you have a
lot that is amazing amazing just a
teaser and shala will be bringing you
more subscribe right now so you don't
miss the programs we're going to be
putting up here in Bosnia
[Music]